pleu martinique râler tout revient en
force pour sa quatrième édition du 19 au
21 juillet venez assister à l'un des
plus gros rally de la caraïbe
grosse nouveauté cette année super
spéciale long du front de mer de fort de
france le 19 juillet à partir de 19h le
pilote vont mettre le feu à la ville
les fins et 21 juillet dès 8 heures tous
sur les spéciales de trinité sainte
marié grau moment pour deux jours de
folie et de spectacles attention pour
que la fête soit plus belle respecter
les consignes de sécurité le march micra
litho une expérience à vivre le martin
cranie tour avec la collectivité
territoriale de martinique la ville de
trinité la ville de fort de france